it was icecream come and taste it slips
down your throat cannon I'm Vee I'm a
full-on vegan now season for all vegan
season for 100% vegan Morty hey
everybody who wants some ice cream so a
bunch of you requested meat into an
Easter Egg video for this bonus episode
done by Tara white Justin roiland and
Spencer Grammer with a couple other
people there is a new round of that
merch giveaway - all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video on us a new winner
at the end of this so during the
offseasons he tends to do bonus episodes
like he animated the state of Georgia
versus Rick Allen which is something
that Justin roiland did Dan Harmon did
way back during the season 3 Comic Con
panel so that wasn't this past year was
the year before that but because it's so
short it's jam-packed with Easter eggs
so they go to this intergalactic ice
cream shop but whole ice cream mr. poopy
butthole
I guess he owns a chain of restaurants
maybe that's what he did in his time off
between seasons they just drive by and
you see graffiti for things from the
show as well as the names of people that
worked on this so like there's a bill
cipher gravity falls symbol here there's
some meeseeks there's this weird moment
where rick censors himself from dropping
an f-bomb but that might just be to
circumvent YouTube censorship rules
because some of the dialogue that Justin
roiland and then Spencer Grammer
recorded for this is original and some
has taken from the Rick and Morty
virtual reality video game so some of it
wound up being animated too those audio
clips so if some of the dialogue seemed
weird it's because it was already
pre-recorded dialogue but some of it is
original so that's why Justin roiland is
credited in the episode but as they're
driving by you see different windows
with different characters the first
window are the dogs from justin roiland
dog world cartoon series you see Tara
wise icon strike lock was the person who
did some of the visual effects then you
see Stanford Pines with another version
of Rick playing with his portal gun
another gravity falls so - gravity falls
Easter eggs in this there's no Szechuan
ice cream there's some graffiti for doc
and Marty which is the thing that
eventually became Rick and Morty once
they sold it to Adult Swim there's a
lawyer Morty from episode 1 talking to
judge Morty from that bonus episode
state of Georgia versus Rick
maybe he's trying to get him to look at
his pogs too but you also see the Planet
Express logo from Futurama these are the
characters from Olin Rogers final space
cartoon this balloon is probably a
reference to the it movie then once they
actually get their ice cream Morty is
eating chocolate ice cream with candy
corn in it so I don't know how you feel
about that but I am a big fan of ice
cream but then it glitches out like in
the M night episode as they go back into
the real world and you see him playing
with that robot more teeth that reminds
me of the robot Morty from the old intro
where the face falls off and Jerry just
completely flips out but you see a
pickle experiment here like he's
thinking about turning himself into a
pickle again you see robot Morty parts
all over the garage the chips that he
pulls out of the robot Morty's brain is
from pocket Morty's and then the pocket
Morty's theme plays over the end credits
but there are a couple fourth wall
breaks like where Rick says this is
canon when he says that I've had five
Morty's that's just a joke on the idea
that our Morty isn't his original Morty
I know everybody has all kinds of
theories about that and then the other
fourth wall break is when Morty starts
talking about himself in third person
saying that Morty will be vegan in
season four but then Rick pulls out the
mind eraser from episode eight so that's
just a joke on the idea that it might be
canon for the next five seconds before
Morty gets his mind erased and he goes
back to normal before season four starts
and then the really cool thing about
that summer phone call at the end is
that's actually Spencer Grammer calling
in and leaving dialog for them to use in
this bonus episode and apparently Morty
isn't a good texture but he's dead and
floating in space just like campaign
manager Morty at the end of episode 7
once he tries to reveal the identity of
evil Morty so it's actually a really
cool bonus episode it's not really can
into the series even though Justin Royal
and did work on it they just do cool
stuff like this between seasons but let
me know what you guys think of it in the
comments below and let me know if there
are any Easter eggs that you spotted
that I didn't mention in the video but
they've also got a special contest that
they're doing to do commentary with them
for the season 3 DVD they probably won't
record that til early next year because
the DVD usually takes about six months
to come out after season's end so it's
not gonna be for a while but this is
that clip here they make fun of a couple
of real-life things in this that I'll
explain they're a couple references to
things that have happened in the
hi i'm dan harmon and i'm justin roiland
we are the creators of Rick and Morty
and we are inviting you to come do
commentary on the season 3 DVD with us
when we record the DVD commentary we
take it very seriously we don't screw
around you know we don't we don't get
drunk or any of that kind of stuff we do
it right so before each commentary we do
a little practice session yeah so here
we'll show you here we go hey Rick yeah
what's up Morty I'm busy I want to drink
out of your flask where did you get my
flask Morty
give it back I don't think so buddy this
is my favorite episode a Justin's second
favorite give me my flask oh oh wait oh
thanks for letting me live here Rick
structural problems were a particular
obstacle on this episode no problem mr.
poopy butthole
mr. poopy butthole a lot of people don't
know is actually my friend one adult
meeseeks
that's canon oh I can't get the TV to
work he sounds like me Rick we know
Morty he does sound a lot like you come
on let's go here's another cheap lazy
walk cycle seems like every time someone
needs to go somewhere they're suddenly
shot from the hips up the TV's working
fine wait a minute this was a trick yeah
it was a trick just stand back Morty
stand back and let like grandpa do what
he does best
I didn't think a musical number was a
good idea for this next part but Justin
insisted here we go
haha
TV set wasn't work and it was broken
then it wasn't really broken I lied to
you
I like to eat [ __ ] oh Jesus it's not
really a good musical number Rick you
didn't really land it it's true we
didn't land it I thought we made up for
it with the love scene yeah Rick I never
tell you this enough but I love you
Morty I never tell you this enough but
you're a piece of [ __ ] anyway it'll be
something like that get the idea so they
make fun of themselves for getting drunk
during commentaries which is something
that they totally do but you may
remember that they did something like
this last year the omae's winner got to
be this person who was killed by the
demons when they made him question his
faith
they make the joke about canonizing mr.
poopy butthole as an adult meeseeks
which is just hilarious I love the fact
that any time Dan Harmon says something
he could actually make that joke
that's canon that's something that we're
totally gonna stick to and they just
completely forget about it but you
probably also noticed that behind them
there there's a whiteboard that reads
season four secrets with a bunch of
gibberish written on it it's so blurry I
can't make out what the actual gibberish
says but let me know in the comments if
you can but in reality there's nothing
here that spoilery for season four there
are no actual secrets that they give
away but the other cool thing that just
happened is is the people who manage the
Rick and Morty's subreddit contacted me
and asked me about doing videos for
season 1 and season 2 during a big
re-watch that they want to organize but
I don't think that's gonna happen til
next year but leave all your Rick and
Morty video requests in the comments
below
congratulations - HM Kenny or the latest
merch giveaway winner please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details you
can click here for my new season 4 video
and you can click here for all my other
Rick and Morty videos thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]